take a little more mentoring
the real West attitude
Tony he's kind of keeping a real close
eye on him and making sure that he's a
worthy recruit for the Avengers he's
right and gifted guy had very talented
guy Peter Parker is constantly learning
throughout the movie and he is trying to
prove himself to Tony that he is ready
to be an Avenger he is old enough to
take on bigger talk how do you find me
you put a tracker in my shoes
I prepare a dinner suit including this
year Wow I saw that relationship is like
a big brother relationship don't do
anything I would do what not very much
and definitely don't do anything I
wouldn't do a little gray area in there
and that's where you operate
it's not a hug I'm just grabbing the dog
for you
I still got it maybe I flash it up and
go with this oh come on sure NBA Finals
party I need to sign off on the guest
list
I left the guest list to you I said keep
it sophisticated done good your bite the
kid you said keep it sophisticated why
do you hate fun you really want me to
invite the kid if I invite the care that
I gotta babysit I like the kid I want to
invite the kid can I please shave us off
no you may not because your team lost
therefore you have to look like me
indefinitely which one go for third
option get out
Friday run a final check on the party
list question Captain Steve Rogers too
soon sending invites no way I'm gonna
watch the NBA Finals with mr. stork so
you're gonna let me go huh nice try
buddy
Oh
perfect timing I need to go downtown and
get me snacks with Tim Duncan happy to
game starting here faster than delivery
with the whole thing now remember it's
for Tim Duncan so nothing fancy just the
fundamentals come on let's go I'm
expecting change
you got to really ruin up my night
just want to watch the game I think I
know that guy hey happy kids where are
you mr. stark mad I'm not there
devastating
where are the crackers I'm getting them
right now here you
Wow your DJ get rid you spider-man what
are you doing here I'm going to the
finals parties darks party I'm going to
well can we get a picture it's
good-looking thank you
Wow could me that that we have first
another one another another look I got
to go put my pin keep it change can't
believe I'm watching this play mr. stark
[Music]
[Applause]
MJ MJ called me magic is so for Tim
Duncan he's right over there
[Music]
did you see you look want to watch the
game
[Applause]
yeah my change he's a great you what Ron
thanks this is race day my start was
helping her mother's game with his suit
and the tech and all that good evening
here
hello congratulations on being a trained
access here's his full capabilities
thank you the shoot is the coolest thing
that has ever happened to me was just a
dream come true you have 500 on the
oscillation or combination said it was
cold well create our web grenade
reconnaissance run whoa that's really
cool
hands come Atma
activate taser webs super jump
web link there's always a real special
moment when I put the suit on this suit
when you want to do would you like to
hear it in pain I can hear what they're
saying
activating advanced incontinent I'm sick
of seeing the router down is all huh I
can keep the suit of course son fit me
[Music]
you